across the country students are making
their voices heard in the gun debate
yesterday thousands walked out of class
to protest the perpetual lack of action
on the issue
in part due to the influence of the gun
lobby meanwhile tragedy is struck again
in the family of fourth grade teacher
irma garcia who died protecting her
students shortly after our cameras
captured video of her husband joe
placing flowers at the memorial site he
died of a heart attack yesterday
the high school sweethearts leave four
children behind
lilia luciano has been speaking to the
families of those who were killed
lilia that is just heartbreaking to hear
that's right michelle and all those 21
lives are memorialized here we have the
opportunity to talk to the family of
jose flores a 10 year old his cross is
right there his sister told us he wanted
to be a police officer when he grew up
because he wanted to protect people from
bad guys and that's precisely the kind
of person who took his life
in a closet underneath a row of his
neatly hung clothing jose flores's
siblings andrea and jaden pull out his
toys one by one
not that one in talking about their
brother they switched between the past
and the present tense did he like music
too or movies or anything music yeah he
loves it he loves music
jose also loved dancing playing video
games and doing cartwheels with andrea
he was among the 19 children and two
teachers killed tuesday at rob
elementary his nine-year-old sister was
hiding in a nearby fourth grade
classroom
we all been under a table
my teacher was closing the blinds and
that's when she got shot but you saw
your t-shirt your teacher being shot yes
what were you thinking
while that was happening you knew your
brother was in another
classroom nearby
i was just worried thinking about him
andrea says police broke into her
classroom and let them out to a safe
meeting spot the only class that wasn't
there was his class jose's stepmom
cynthia herrera and her husband
desperately searched for their kids they
found andrea and then learned jose did
not survive and i just feel guilty even
saying like i'm glad my daughter made it
because i know my stepson did it
his sister now grappling with his death
and the idea of one day having to return
to school i'm scared
that it just might happen again
and i feel like
i just want to drink
but if it happens again it will be next
andrea's teacher who shot survived and
jose's stepmom cynthia told us that he
always struggled in school but for the
first time tuesday he was honored for
his good grades and he couldn't wait to
get home and tell his dad he was so
proud
she is heartbroken there are so many
stories like this it's just hard to
fathom but these lives will live forever
in our memory
dana
lily an entire community grieving there
and those young innocent children they
can't stop thinking of thank you